Riana and pink turned down the Super
Bowl I don't know if I should say back
that's right
turns out reread or pink could have been
headliners for next year's Superbowl
halftime show a source tells et CBS and
the NFL reached out to Rihanna first who
after thinking about the offer decided
to pass due to the NFL and the situation
regarding players kneeling and that she
stands with the players and Colin
Kaepernick guys the limit no rules I
could do whatever I do and exposure
would have been great for Rihanna as
she's planning a new album and tour but
she stuck to what's right in her eyes I
couldn't tell you how happy I had a
second source tells et the NFL was also
in conversations with pink early on who
sang the national anthem ahead of last
year's Superbowl 52
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but because the negotiations took so
long both women decided to move on that
source adds Kaepernick was not mentioned
in those early discussions I've never
been one for the popularity contest kind
of thing and conforming or any of that
in September a source close to the NFL
told ET maroon 5 had signed on for the
highly coveted gig at Super Bowl 53
however the NFL Pepsi and maroon 5 reps
would not comment and no formal
announcement has been made
[Music]